welcome back to the Julian podcast these
marvel cosplaying here ladies and
gentlemen we have Kermit on the table
today who demanded to be a marble
cosplay he's been a good boy right now
he's just sitting here like this he's
like he knows the drill if I'm up here I
have to sit like this you just you're
sitting a little suss but like you so
saw coz planning you're ready to jump up
enough daddy's coffee right into the
mixer right into our Apollo just like
there's all these holes on the top of it
for like air ventilation it's gonna
spill the coffee through every single
one of those oh that's a good boy oh
that's a much better you see he knows
the drill
yeah cuz he wants it no he doesn't know
he doesn't know the drill in five
minutes he's gonna be begging to get
inside your onesie your comfortable ones
he made by me and ease me and these guys
a proud sponsor of the Jenna Jillian
podcast you can get this very onesie on
your person and your friends person and
as many as you need there's three times
softer than cotton just as comfortable
as their underwear
these have tacos and hot sauce on them
I'm a big fan of both of those things so
I'll go to me undies COMSOL Oscoda join
and get 15% of your first pair of free
shipping and your satisfaction will be
guaranteed also guys post mates you want
something delivered use post mates
anything it can be from a drugstore it
can be from a market and can be from
Taco Bell to get this food like the food
you can get a taco onesie and get tacos
delivered to you the dynamic duo
download the post mates app use code
Jenna and Julian that's $100 of free
delivery credit for your first 7 days
you get when you use that code peachy no
this table ain't big enough for the two
ears get on out of here
cute Julian come on look at him he's
like I promise please set me on table
one time I'd be good boy the only
problem is I think marble realized that
we just started podcasting and that he's
not up here so he's looking at me like
what the hell he'll forget in like five
seconds well when we came in the room he
darted straight to this bed on the floor
where they all sit sometimes and cuddled
up and was so excited
permit demanded to be up here so I was
like alright let's switch things up come
if you can promise be a good boy you get
to sit up here and look at him and being
a good boy alright we'll see how long it
lasts I was so confused
he's always confused he is I was getting
dressed this morning and he just started
me locked eyes with just like wait a
second who the hell are you it's like he
copied morphing into a different skin
yeah I don't like that you being a good
boy
if only he felt how soft the ones he was
he would have liked it yeah Carmen
really likes this ones that he tries to
get inside of it yeah I know it's nasty
it's really uncomfortable well it's
uncomfortable because I'm just like you
know I'm wearing my underwear my bra let
under here but it's if you put Carmen in
here he'll just start like licking my
stomach is love God yeah if you have any
like exposed skin he will lick it mmm
new topic
it sounds like a horror creature if you
have exposed skin it will lick it he is
he's a he's a real-life boogeyman so
gross he imagined like a demon that only
wanted to find people with exposed skin
so they could just lick it like they
have that that side of them that's
friendly right - like fool people what
is that is that known as like trickery
yeah trickster god the trickster gods
but he's like seriously the devil and so
then deep down he's just like a an evil
licking monster but he doesn't like want
to harm you he just wants to like scare
you and lick you but his licks cause
harm yeah maybe they give you like a
rash or they do their skin off yeah they
take your skin on oh but like not right
now licks you and then over time it
starts to hurt and then your skin just
melts off
[Music]
Karm is that true have you been doing
that - he come are you gonna make our
skin fall off he's trying to give me
rashes though he doesn't even hide it a
lot of people are allergic to Kermit I
try and warn people because he really
likes everyone so I'll walk up to
someone and then start licking their
hand in their arm then they'll be like
yeah and then ten seconds later it
doesn't happen to me at all but it's
happened to several people that he's
then all of a sudden they just break out
in hives like a komodo dragon I can't
hold it a shirtless yeah well you're
also allergic to like his fur like he
gives you hives well yeah because he
licks his fur does he know that we're
talking about yeah he does that's like
he's looking at you like that alright
but you can stay be a good boy look at
ya don't jinx it I know but just all of
a sudden at once
he'll just decide that he's done and
then jump onto my lap you know mm-hmm
it's just the sudden sudden sareth
movements speaking of theremins you want
to play incoherent we had to play
incoherent we're going to play a game
known as the incoherent bobble you want
to cuddle with bunny all right
bunnies like don't go [ __ ] near my
bad dude I saw this game because a bunch
of people on the Internet been playing
it because it's such a fun game to play
and just seems like a really great time
and it just seems like right up our
alley
as people that like playing snake oil
one of the games will be played on the
podcast snake oil snake oil we played
Shark Tank ah snake oil things where we
draw things out of a cup mm-hmm pizza
party only hiding I seek only the fire
in the town the donkey I still cannot
believe you did that
that's pretty sick you hit on top of a
stepladder for me it's pre dough what
can I say we have a great podcast there
we do no but I saw people playing this
and it was making me like genuinely
laugh this is funny
yeah basically one side of the card says
a real phrase and it seems like they're
broken up into three categories I forget
what the yellow one is like just normal
blue is party and red is kinky culture
pop culture pop culture party and kinky
so the way it works is you ever see like
on Twitter or you know one of those
things that your friends will text you
and says like read these words and they
were the words are nonsense and then you
read him but when you read them out loud
it says something else
that's what this game is so it gives you
a card with a bunch of words on it and
depending on the category if you read it
right and you can let it kind of sink in
in your brain you'll understand what
it's trying to get you to say yeah and
you're supposed to do it within 60
seconds and you're allowed to give one
hint apparently but we don't have any
rules we don't have any rules ah [ __ ] it
who cares
ever since episode one of this podcast
we established that there are no rules
no rules so we're gonna read
phonetically but the words on the card
and then we're gonna try to like read it
all together
and you can guess too so you can play
along if you want you want to go first
you grab that box there we go all right
so you ready to play where's the guide
for okay yellows pop culture party is
blue and Greta's kinky that's easy to
remember what do you want right here
yeah just party Oh party okay let me
read it
show it to me I'm reading the phonetics
fizz dub hum Bing those are the words
that she has to read yeah you have to
the point is you have to show me there
I'm showing you the card see but if you
show me the card I can read them fine
whatever and it's party party fizz dub
humming this dumb popping there's dub on
bing I can you want a hint I don't think
I'm gonna be very good at this game
no repass sir this up to Bing physicist
dub poppin this StubHub Inge say the
same thing yeah I know that's one of the
games I may give you a hint you're
hostile that was actually hot tubbing I
think is the last word no no this dub a
Bing me do you want the hit on the car
yeah boy do you want the hint on the car
oh good it is you want a hint on the
card or a hint from me in my words on
the card okay clubbing this dub Humpty
that didn't help at all
fists fists puppy there you go thank you
that was high-fiving you in your turn
read me your card I'm gonna read you a
pop-culture card because we all know
that that's your strong suit see look
look what I can do it I can show you the
card
beep perv favor ready yeah beep per
favore be for favor
wait what is yello pop-culture beep her
favor beep perfect ever be per favore
Bieber fever how'd you get that yeah
do you know what the hint says Canadian
sickness y'all sick symptoms include
accelerated heart rate and high pitched
screaming Bieber Bieber Bieber fever
beeper fever all right so I'm winning I
got mine oh yeah you did but I'm still
winning oh okay cuz I got mine first I
get it okay sick we you know he's kind
of in the way no no let's shove him no
he's great no he's all right we're doing
our first kinky one it's gonna be kinky
here we go Jenna read us the phonetics
miss tion Harry boss H tion oh this is a
good one mission Harry Bosch boss itchin
missionary boss kitchen faster
missionary Boston you don't know mission
Harry boss action faster missionary
Washington Reza missionary Madison read
the second part faster
Harry bought know it son it's tion it
shouldn't it's tion no it's not edge
that's what it says okay read from boss
faster kitchen from boss to the end fast
Bachchan now the whole thing watch it
[Laughter]
give me a hint
No okay the starter pose missionary
position I know it was just funny it's
funny from my end because I know what it
is
and so it sounds like it tion no I know
I know it's hard yeah you did well
though fine you get a kinky one give me
a kinky one don't look I'm looking don't
look I'm a look me uh Leif Mia Khalifa
damn it what that was easy
do another one that was bad no no I want
another one no you can get one after I
hop culture for you far rat turn it Heep
rod her good faster fara turn it he
brought her for eternal he brought her
don't try to justify like that he
brought her all right turn it he bought
her yes sir
fara turn it he brought her far
head-turner we brought her it's getting
worse I'm so bad at this let me know if
you want to hear know what I'm better at
one of those puzzles with this give you
a bunch of letters and you got to decode
it and like make it make a sentence this
horrible far-out turn it he broader the
hint is greekish
am i dumb no all right turn a he brought
her showing it to me do you have a hit
[Music]
college fraternity he brought her no not
he brought her read the last part
Trinity party no but far-right turn it
but you already got fraternity why are
you dancing at far eternity you already
got that word far eternity
party no Rotter
Rotter if you and I are in the same
brother yes thank you
hold on I'm bad I'm dumb oh my god can't
do it if there's nothing to be bad at I
would think this is a good thing to be
bad at cuz this is literal nonsense
so that's why I'm good at it this
doesn't go to my brain right womb Hank
rush when stay home Hank rush since a
woman crush Wednesday we'll hang crush
Wednesday won't hang crush Wednesday
boom Hank crush Wednesday
well man crush don't say well main
questions that me and it's hump day
what on Instagram hashtag WCW won't hang
Chris wants it well women crush
Wednesday yeah my least favorite hint is
say it faster doesn't work well that's
just when I tell myself okay every day
in my brain yeah alright blue we're
gonna do a party one bad at this deal
with it
Red Solo Cup red you said it yeah I know
give me a second Red Solo Cup yeah okay
it's a red sole oak yeah some of these
are mad easy all right let's put the
timer out mind that oh sorry excuse me
in such a good boy
look at him your turn doing his best
Marvel cosplay his tongue sticking out
the side of his mouth
we're doing Party Party dis sickin ate
it ryf her too sick and ate it right fur
too sick and ate it right for the second
rated the sick and ADA Trevor to see
Canadian River this one's hard
the second the second ad river okay and
as the real MVP tonight the second eight
arrived her rife right
sometimes you hand your keys to a their
thinking it to designated driver
sounds weird the only double Ds who will
let you in their car hello are you
roasting way to make it weird in Co here
okay we're doing it's like only kinky
ones now Julian fairy King tush eats
fairy Kinta sheets very gentle sheets
nice fairy kinto sheets freaking machine
nice I'm sorry to get the hang of it yes
very contagious an important life skill
to them are you kinto sheets yes fairy
Kenta she's just operating away you know
who's a fairy Kenta she her mother
battement he's a freaking exposed skin I
like is that your foot well cannot wait
to lick me as well being snack or
lollipop lollipop human lollipop looking
at me no don't don't don't
he's been such a good boy yeah you being
such a good boy buddy
okay you go she's being really good
you're good you're good you're good boy
good yeah thank you one okay give me a
kinky one fake up who faked a cub oops
fake huh boobs fake boobs fake boobs
fake boobs Kermit now he's gonna start
crying because we said fake boobs oh
okay loop rique hand
lubricant lubricant that could be pop
culture that could be party that could
be any of them automotive automotive
hobby all right give me a kink wrestling
style
speaking of wrestling style lubricant
did you see Royce remixes edit of Frank
the tank from old school no it was when
Frank the tank does the beer bong at the
party except it cuts to me pouring the
white claw in your mouth with my mouth
oh Sid ton knife ace Sid - knife ace sit
on my face sit on my face oh my god the
game oh my god I'm playing the game
the hint is VIP seats Kinks only them
speaking of which
yeah fer rents switch pen of it's for
rent switch pen of it's for rent switch
pens the pen of it's for rent switch pen
of it's for when switch pin of it's for
in switch benefits keeping it casual for
rinse switch pen of it's not in your
head is not burn sweet sharp end of its
no for rent switch pen of it's for rent
switch pen of its I have a give you
another hint okay when two people are
dating except they don't want to label
it for in switch pen of its nope not
that Wow
I'm dumb give me one kink it up i wanna
real bore knock rough he bore knock
rough he pornography pornography you
read that once and it makes sense okay
ready yep oh god
hye-won Xuan's height off may now you
got to remove it because it's being a
nuisance please oh you did so good
literally didn't he made it halfway
through and then something the standards
are so low for him aren't they
high want shoes ins height off me oh no
hi Juan Xuan's height off me hmm
hi Juan Xuan's height off me I want you
inside me come on off me I want Xuan's
height off me I want you inside me oh my
god TOS who's calling the police
he's got demonetised all right wait Y
post uh Nate's post mates in your brain
post me no no this one says post me know
it doesn't on the back the hint is use
cogenitor Dillian so I guess you guys
download the post mates happen use code
generally and dude the game told you to
do it so you have to it's an awesome
delivery app that makes it so you can
have your favorite foods and items
around town deliver it right to your
door you don't have to go anywhere you
just download the post mates app 24
hours a day every day of the year
that's 365 days if you didn't know they
will deliver to your house you don't
have to talk to anyone you off to you
don't have to keep a drawer full of
those pamphlet menus like you had when
you grew up remember that no all on your
phone you just log on the postmates app
type in your address and you see what's
in your area and then you scroll through
these beautiful pictures of food and
you're like salivating you're like what
do I want what do I want that and then
you click it order through the menu BAM
post mates on their way to pick it up
and you can track them with the live
updated
map truly an incredible app that we use
literally all the time right now go to
posts mates in the app store download
the app and use code Jenna Julian you
get $100 of free delivery credit for
your first seven days so check it out
use post mates if you instead of just
going out to get food post made it check
it out make the food come to you make
the food come to you also guys me undies
longtime proud sponsor of the gender
lean podcast you know what love is in
the air Valentine's Day right around one
shoe inside Hoffman okay that is an
appropriate ease but you get the idea
right now you can get you and your loved
one a me undies Valentine's Day gift
whether it's a onesie bralette underwear
socks other underwear isn't hers he's a
nurse his they have cut off they have
couple orders so if you and your loved
one your special someone you can place
an order to where you will get the same
style and print for like a dual gift for
something like Valentine's Day it's very
romantic it's a nice gesture and it's
the softest underwear you can get three
times softer than cotton definitely look
into it if you're stumped on what to get
for Valentine's Day you can't go wrong
with some Mandie's so go to me undies
comm /gen and Julianne get 15% off of
your first order
free shipping that's pretty nice at 100%
satisfaction guarantee
because Valentine's Day is all about
satisfaction Wow okay okay bye you go
Julian let's do it
trees hum trees hum trees hum trees hum
tree some trees some threesome threesome
that's a threesome I got it very nice
Julian okay
oh I said something else I'll hike peg
bus hike
and hot dawn hi this is way more
enjoyable for the person holding the
card and knows what they're saying I'll
hike peg bus hiking hot done hi you
actually sound like you're speaking like
a whole new language right I'll hike peg
bus hiking hot and high hiking hot on
high hike in hot and high I cannot I'm
speaking German I'll hike pegye bus this
is definitely German I like big bus I
like I like I like big butts and I
cannot lie
nice Wow I'm proud of me for that one
you should be that was good to him kill
Bop logon drop it pop lock and drop it
damn it let me get another one okay
everything's bad some of them are really
good some of them are pretty bad deep
hag King d-pad King deep hacking deep
hacking deep hacking deep hack king deep
deep egging divi divi King D backing do
Jimmy King hint it's not coffees what it
says deep hat King what what's not
coffee
what's a drink that's not coffee deep
hacking that's not the answer deep
packing you can answer my question teeth
yeah he bag yeah tea bagging yeah tea
bagging yeah that's pop culture and
kinky and video game video games all
right other kink yeah let's
- epochal okay oh my god
tint hurt 8/10 art 8/10 er Tate tinder
date tinder date nice tinder date TN boy
mourn Inc have derp Hill morning have
türbe hill morning have der pill
morning-after pill oh my god that is
morning-after pill okay alright then
what you giving me boy kink as [ __ ] sell
fur Foggs you got this sulfur fogs sell
fur fogs sulfur fogs that you can't like
nod as if that's it
silver pot that's not a health professor
don't propose sulfur frogs sofa Prague's
sell for folks you saying it so for
folks
yeah [ __ ] no sulfur [ __ ] no not sell
for fox silver fogs sulfur fogs you want
hit yes Gramps Gramps sulfur fogs yeah
say it fastest so provoked so from an
old hot dude
sulfur fogs I don't know what's an old
hot dude a DILF
so for Foggs you're saying the first
part is sulfur so it's color so so
sulfur colored so fur colored yeah no
the other color that you're saying
sulfur fogs what color does an old man
have I don't know what color just seems
like it's not up to him what do you mean
well by nature it's not up to him or her
this could be either I don't understand
what's happening when you're old what
color is your vibe I don't know let
probably lots of different colors up
there up where top up top what colors
the top like sure they were oh it's not
about clothing sofas nature's clothing
up top what nature's clothing up top on
their head
silver five thank God I helped out on
that one Wow a top what color are they
silver fox can be used for a woman and
man right I don't know I think you can
use it on whatever you would like
here you go Julian rage imp owner rage
and poner rage imp owner raging boner
I'm owning this is so dumb I'm a dummy
dumb dumb and I can't figure out words
the hint for raging boner was very erect
[Laughter]
okay
Bop Inc Dutch hairy bopping Dutch cherry
poppin - Cherry
you're saying it like a reggae something
popping the cherry so you popping the
cherry you got it you got it
la la pink it is poppin cherry poppin
Dutch Harry stop popping touch popping
the cherry oh my god high five my dude
it was a nightmare
peach yeah cold hen chow hair cold hench
out hair Colton chow hair
Colton shower is it shower
Colton Chow hair cold in shower cold in
cold in shower cold hence out hair cold
and shower
Colton shower can I have a hint no it's
peepee time golden shower Oh cut nasty
oh my god that wasn't the hint I made up
his peepee time okay here we go oh this
is a good one bud Paul ugh I feel you
know what this is is it a Bud plug butt
plug
what part butt plug butt plug I'm good
at that one not like in real life
oh my god just at the word that one's
easy
boy fill it afford or do I pronounce it
filet filet filet okay
filet afford conned dumb filet afford
condom
it's definitely condom at the end filet
afford condom full life flavored condom
flavored condom flavored okay I didn't
think I'd be saying that today I didn't
think I'd be saying that today oh this
is kid hang might dig Wed why are you
shaking your head cuz this is nasty kid
hang might dig wet kid hang my big when
it sounds like kidding my dick wet my
dig when no say might dig Wayne might
dig when my dig Wed kidding might dig
when what you had the second part nailed
my big wet so is that Mike my dick wet
my dig Wed yeah yeah Mike dig would know
something about Mike might digwydd kid
hanging my dick would getting my dick
wet what yeah thank you
good job Thanks oh really thank you I
wouldn't I wouldn't rot my world
oh yeah yep pay aunt ding
at panting happy ending happy ending hih
panting panting panting panting panting
panting panting panting panting hint
this says a joyous finale how panting
happy ending
good job Julian we're doing all the
kinks all the kinks Hey reap you bus
hey rebus can you get her done why she's
my mom I love her no no her name's peach
she's really cute she loves everybody
hey reap you bus you reap you bus has
that hairy pubes oh yeah the reap you
bus why do you have to why can't it just
be like pubic hair why does it have to
be hairy pure heart some of these are
really clever and then some of them look
like they're yes yeah
pants eggs shoe well pansexual pansexual
pansexual yeah why is that kinky why is
the sexuality kinky it's I don't know
let's go ladies men this is good pick
tic kin hurt she picked a kinnor she
picked akin her she picked a Kenpachi
picnic and turkey picked up in her she
picked in her cookie picked in her
coochie picked in her kerchief this this
goes outside the bedroom like you can
say this about things in life mmm big
dinner coochie okay pick dinner coochie
give you a hint now pick tender Curt
yeah cocky
dick energy Oh okay so it helps me if I
whisper it does it yes or did it just
right there no randomly it's gotta help
me in the future
okay how's that your new strat yeah I'm
gonna whisper it 200 IQ whisper it sent
it Inc nips sending newts sending nudes
yeah gnomes bath I was born give me
another don't look highl I get her of
time I kiss her of high like hit her of
highlight kiss her of high like hitter
of get her off get her off highlight get
her off get her off high lie get her off
high like hits her off highlighter kit
off yeah hide later kid off good job
that's looking no high like hit her off
how I kid rough high like hitter of of I
like it rough yeah sounds rough you're
gonna organize all those cuz they're
different colors don't care okay
aim hole beats amyl beats means anal
beads oh it does work see I'm telling
you cuz you can like hear it doing
another hint for that one what booty
jewelry stop babies knock it off
when the booty jewelry hits
[Laughter]
kink me try whispering it for real no no
no the she's hot she's hot she's pop it
works it does she spot hit the g-spot
yeah I just so because it sounds nasty I
wonder if it would work for pop culture
or party probably no only for King oh
okay okay you want to do a real quick
pop culture one break up the sickness
yeah I'm ready go
this is terrible come on okay culture
these are really cringey hold on John I
was just throwing shade
what find me a good one okay these are
all just like dumb sayings I guess that
one was Yas Queen yeah that was a scream
fit he sheds off cray-cray Fifty Shades
of Grey I'm telling you you whisper
about you sexual - that was not pop
culture that was pretty much a sexual a
feel like I've hacked this game give me
a if you know if you whisper it you can
hear it better I don't think that's true
lung air toned gayer no whisper it hair
don't care I don't know what that says
don't care you're sick but like you say
it perfectly when you whisper I don't
care yeah long hair don't care
yeah long hair don't care I figured out
how to beat this game okay let's test it
I'm gonna give you a big Virgo and you
party not good it's something you
discuss I'm gonna give you a party one
that's what this is nice brah jet Isle
Vaughan mitten project - it's like
projectile vomiting
you are much better when you whisper
alright guys if you're gonna play this
game with your friends just use that
strap whisper why does that work I don't
know why why is that work I know maybe
you can hear like hear it better I'm
telling you even maybe it's it might be
just for you though doc Keys tile now
whisper it doggy style donkey style
doggy style key style
what is donkey style whatever you want
it to be but I don't know we just
friends but donkey style could be a
friendship thing yeah okay so what would
that entail I don't know one of us hits
on top of the other
okay sin goal Lander I can't read it
your hands in the way to help sin goal
Lander head eat whoo
mink oh no this is single sinkhole and
ready to mingle
yeah say single and ready to mingle at
this game you beat it I'm a Virgo it has
nothing to be in Virgo but I figured out
hack cuz I'm a Virgo
knocked up knocked up I'll give you
another one
you got party give me a party where you
go fart in [ __ ] up lick fart in [ __ ] up
lick fartin [ __ ] public farting in
public
not going just spoke to feed whoever
wrote that card showing up to work that
day farting in public yeah they didn't
write Yas Queen the person that wrote
farting in public that's what I'm saying
that's what I'm saying that took a
little bit of like you know foresight
like well it's gonna be funny when
someone discovers they've said it Yas
Queen no farting in public no farting in
public yes yeah let's give you a kinky
one I feel like the writing could use
some help in this game totally well it's
like the when cards against humanity'
first came out there's people that just
like wrote things like cats period
mm-hmm or like sunny day yeah and then
they and then some guy showed up at work
and was like a super soaker filled with
cat pee and you're like you deserve a
raise yeah and also let's hire more of
that guy mm-hmm okay
I can't read it your hands in the way
you know Hut
the this is Hayes hey up out pick ends
you know Hut the hey hey hey hey
about Pickens you know what they say
about big hands nice good job you're
whispering technique is flawless
that one's a terrible card though you
know what they say about be hints and
then on the card it says they can hold
more popcorn big high-fives Prince I'm
sorry come I'm not sorry
donkey style donkeys oh I got a better
donkey style one of us stands behind the
other and then pointed in front just
kicks them in the chest
[ __ ] yeah dude hunk like cohorts hunk
like cohorts Blackhearts hunk like
cohorts my cards hung like a horse yeah
I feel like I've figured out how to be a
donkey style Julian what
morn hang would Marty what I'm - good
morning - good morning would too
powerful
Jake hot
yum amok Cavey huh j-jake yum I'm
Octavia I don't know do it fast Jake I'm
Octavia Jake oh man what a view huh I
don't know okay say it and I'll drop you
a beat Jake hot yo man watch carry huh I
don't know I don't need a hit jkv huh no
that's not helping me the first word
isn't Jake its shake shake yup mama ma
ke V huh
what is Hut shake mud hut shake hot mom
yacht shake hut yeah MOC MOC AV huh
shake heart
yeah mommy shake what your mama gave you
yeah my god the hint is drop it like
it's hot
fellow kids Oh sir call shirt Oh No
circle jerk oh my god okay
the hint is seeking out people with the
same opinions so you can sit around
agreeing with each other oh that's like
okay online circle do not only a literal
one and then literal and is helping hand
okay loose your fortune can get heat
kitty losing your virginity boring it's
a boring car tell him get up give me
another one come for their writing come
for it
my grope beam his so much whispered
micropenis okay hurry match hurry
shack you'll Asian premature ejaculation
premature ejaculation how do you know I
think yeah I think you're me Minh how am
i meaning I don't know I think you try
harder when you whisper no unconsciously
no I think well so here's my theory
I'm gonna try it without my headset
because I think like there might be
something helpful when you hear it
whispered that it like blurs the sound
of the words I didn't make it so you can
hear I'll take it off my head sex I want
to see if it actually works
yeah if you were to just actually
whisper it Chad
drool hat it's not as easy without your
head no and this is also a bad card
chatroulette yeah it still helped a
little
another one okay that's stripper pole
it's a strip hit purple sped doors wall
ho spiders
spitter swallow it does it still works
it still works
wow I'm so impressed
my turn whisper it telling you
toggled hurt heat whom he do me doctor
yeah yeah I don't know maybe it's cuz
it's like it's not as loud I think it's
a volume thing mm-hmm
you know yeah yeah don't move hug don't
you [ __ ] something [ __ ] right don't you
[ __ ] - [ __ ] don't do [ __ ] it's a
question - [ __ ] want to [ __ ] do you want
to [ __ ] care - [ __ ] down - [ __ ] care -
[ __ ] care - [ __ ]
mmm okay let's see one more okay one
more each bra silly and wax Brazilian
wax that was bad for wren shook his sing
forensic vinyl that's not right
french kissing cows out to the middle
schooler who wrote this card all right
hit me
mom micropenis these aren't good give me
a good one there you go Julian mm-hmm
calm he'd at tea all the timer ran out
just now I guess we're out of time
mm-hmm well I guess that was fun one
would be inclined to say GG's GG's that
was fun
what's a good time it was interesting
you mix them all up Oh Mike oh they're
all Julie yeah that's how we do it the
airy style my dude this is a fun game I
think this is one of those like it's
probably if they keep making versions of
it it's in the early stages like I
remember when we first started playing
cards against humanity' we started
selecting cards that were really good
and then over the course of firing a
couple boxes we had like an Opie box
where they were all the best cards oh
yeah we call it the trump deck the trump
deck like you know when you play euchre
and you have Trump so I would say of all
the trump cards because there were also
some of those cards that if I was the
one reading them they were like my trump
cards look if somebody played it like it
just wins it just gets us every time so
we took out all of the soft shitty
bodies yeah that [ __ ] like every time
[ __ ] back and forth forever or
pooping back and forth forever a super
soaker filled with cat pee like some of
those cars waited [ __ ] there was um
Oprah Winfrey eating a Lean Cuisine yeah
maybe we tell all the cards except for
the incredibly good ones and then over
the years we had like a ultimate
ultimate deck yeah so maybe there was no
bad cards this could get better it's
good it's but it could get definitely
better yeah I think so this hires just
poach some of the cards against
humanity' employees yeah well I think
that the gist of the game not that like
we're trying to critique anyone's
[ __ ]
but I think in order for this to be
really fun the phrase that the person
ends up saying has to be really funny it
has to be it can't just be like ah
scream Yas Queen yeah cuz I'm here don't
care it like the sentence has to be
funny cuz they have to be like oh my god
I can't believe I just said that like
when I said micropenis it took me way
back yeah yeah although to be fair I
mean we only played for awhile like an
hour so maybe there's a lot of cards in
here that are very funny that we didn't
get to but like the whole thing should
be funny yeah I go full go full tilt
with it me yeah like take the naughty
cards so give us a deck that's like full
toast
yeah give us like the after dark deck
give us the after dark yeah that's a
little thirsty thirst teeth or stay at
Thirsty Thursday like great I said
Thirsty Thursday okay if I'm playing
this at a party I'm like gonna chug my
drink after that cuz I'm bored anyway
it's a fun game it's really fun but I
feel like you can whisper your way
through that and win yeah Jenna found
like a pretty solid hack there you
installed some cheats some malware thank
you
well it's not cheating good game it's
adapting thank you guys for listening
and hanging out while you read read
things phonetically the wrong way I hope
you guys have a wonderful week we'll be
back next week also keeping my
Valentine's Day is right around the
corner so you know you know what to do
you know what to do anyway have a
wonderful week guys thank you for
hanging with us another podcast and
we'll see you on the next one
[Music]
[Music]